In 1948, the historian Arthur Schlesinger
asked fellow historians to rate US
presidents. The pollsters soon followed suit,
and they've been asking Americans to
assess presidents ever since. Barack Obama
leaves office with a solid approval
rating. He's in the mid-fifties in most polls,
but when it comes to job performance, the
verdict is mixed. President Obama
inherited a terrible economy. Although
Americans see some improvement after
eight years, only a bare majority approve of
the job he's doing here.
Less than half approve of the job he's
doing handling terrorism or foreign policy
generally. Sixty-one percent believe that the US
is less respected that in the past.
As for Obamacare, views about the law have
generally been more negative than
positive since its passage. A solid
majority disapprove of the way the
president has handled the issue. However,
only thirty-five percent favor straight
repeal. Finally, two-thirds in a pew survey say
race relations have gotten worse since
2008. Only nine percent say they've gotten better. First
drafts of history are always subject to
revision. At this point, we know that
President Obama is personally more popular
than his policies. To learn more about my take on
Obama's legacy, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.